so to start off if you guys had the
opportunity to swap roles with anybody
in the Star Wars film franchise would
you think you wanna oh yeah he's one of
coolest like I'm really sorry we saw
yesterday I like there are some gestures
he does when he does the things that he
does are so cool like I genuine
do I dare ask you for your your force
gesture what would it look like if
you've never do just wait in the eyes
just like I love that and they've been
never you know just like a mean side up
do you have a force gesture um yeah I do
it from the other side of the room with
my head turns that way so no wood no boo
sneaky so obviously right now everybody
is super into baby Yoda melting hearts
all over the place and we want to
continue that so right in lines with the
whole like for the babies first idea if
you had to witness baby Yoda's first
fill in the blank what would it be it's
like first Christmas first food or bath
something like that like his first like
its first walking yeah I think a little
Yoda walk is adorable I feel like his
first words would he speak the way that
he does yeah you know like does he just
always speak out of order like things
like if it was like if it was like mama
mama yeah so we've first my mind went to
try but then it's just it's probably
like no try no try to go with Yoda's I
can try it'd be so confusing yeah it
gets I think I'm sticking with first
walks maybe like first little like
toddler dance what am i your feet could
you imagine it with those little baby
odor on your feet
so I was wondering especially for You
Naomi and also for you Kelly having
joined the franchise with the last movie
I know sometimes when you step into your
first big movie like this it can be very
nerve-wracking to ask something that you
might consider a silly question so if
you could go back to the beginning and
ask a question to somebody about the
filmmaking process that you might have
been afraid to ask what would it be
many-to-many I'd like there would be
things around like like camera
technician stuff that was like I always
like was just like staring at the camera
for one I always used to ask like how
much is this camera like how much is
this one look at how much I remember
there was like this dolly that they'd
like push the camera around on but you
can't buy it
20 grand 20,000 and you can't buy it you
can only hire it so I guess it's not 20
grand Kelly what about you I actually
the first one I asked a lot of weird
questions but yeah I think that having
that continued curiosity is really
important for for me and probably for
everyone just to keep learning yeah but
everyone was super nice about asking
questions yeah people are usually quite
curious and I feel like if you're if
you're being inquisitive on set then
it's usually a good thing because to
know what everyone else is doing means
that you're really trying to be part of
the team and be collaborative and like
have a respect for everyone's artistry
and craft so speaking of that just wrap
up here if you were to name an unsung
hero a rising Skywalker not necessarily
someone from the cast just someone on
the crew that made a difference in your
day who would it be a tie for me so he
was the first idea and he would like
beatbox on the on the microphone when he
was like in between takes just a really
good person like never shouted but got
stuff done so Tommy coming he's came